♪♪♪
>>>> WHO THIS?
>> LOOK AT THIS DUDE.
>> IS THAT MR. H.?
THAT'S MY TEACHER FROM SCHOOL.
WHAT HE DOING OUT HERE?
>> HEY.
I THOUGHT I MIGHT FIND YOU HERE.
HAVEN'T SEEN YOU IN SCHOOL MUCH
LATELY.
>> YEAH, LET ME GUESS, YOU CAME
ALL THE WAY DOWN HERE TO BRING
ME BACK, RIGHT?
WHAT'S THE POINT, MR. H.?
YOU THINK I'M GOING TO BE SOME
BIG COLLEGE SUCCESS STORY?
>> IS THAT SO CRAZY?
>> YOU'RE WATCHING TOO MANY
MOVIES, DUDE.
BRAVE TEACHER COMES DOWN TO THE
HOOD TO SAVE HIS GIFTED STUDENT
FROM THE STREETS, RIGHT?
WHAT, NEXT I'M GOING TO HEAR,
MARCUS, YOU'VE GOT POTENTIAL.
>> YOU DO.
>> RIGHT, AND NEXT, MARCUS
YOU'RE SMART?
>> YOU ARE SMART.
>> THEN IT'S LIKE, MARCUS,
YOU'RE A GENIUS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
MARCUS, YOU'RE A GENIUS.
>> AHH.
>> WHY CAN'T YOU SEE YOU'RE A
GENIUS, MARCUS?
>> GENIUS IS THROWN AROUND A
LITTLE TOO MUCH THESE DAYS.
BUT I WILL SAY YOU ARE VERY
BRIGHT AND I BROUGHT YOU THIS.
IT'S YOUR S.A.T. RESULTS.
>> MAN, I THREW THAT IN THE
TRASH.
>> AND I TOOK THEM OUT.
I THINK YOU OWE IT TO YOURSELF
TO SEE HOW YOU DID.
>> MAN, YOU OPEN IT.
YOU'RE THE ONLY ONE THAT CARES.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WELL, YOU GOT AN 880.
>> OUT OF 900?
HERE YOU GO.
OH, MARCUS, WHAT YOU DOING IN
THESE STREETS WHEN YOU GOT A
BASICALLY PERFECT S.A.T. SCORE?
>> NO, YOU DIDN'T.
>> WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT IT,
CRAIG?
>> I KNOW IT'S SCORED OUT
OF 1600, AND AN 880 IS, LIKE,
PRETTY BAD.
>> SHUT UP, CRAIG.
WHEN YOU GONNA FACE IT, MR. H.?
I'M NOT YOUR 'HOOD TO HARVARD
SUCCESS STORY, ALL RIGHT?
>> NO, HARVARD IS DEFINITELY OUT
OF THE QUESTION.
BUT I THINK WITH A LITTLE
STUDYING, YOU CAN GET IT UP
TO 1100.
>> THAT'S STILL NOT THAT GOOD.
>> YES IT IS, TUNEE.
IT'S BETTER THAN ANYBODY ELSE
GOT OUT HERE.
>> I ACTUALLY GOT LIKE A 1260.
>> WELL, YOU ARE BUYING WEED
RIGHT NOW, SO YOU CAN LEAVE.
>> I'M JUST WAITING FOR MY
CHANGE.
I GAVE YOU $100 10 MINUTES AGO,
AND YOU STILL HAVEN'T GIVEN ME
CHANGE.
>> ALL RIGHT, I GOT IT, MAN.
$60 OF WEED --
>> ARE YOU USING A CALCULATOR
FOR THAT?
>> TAKE AWAY A HUNDRED --
>> IT'S 40.
>> GO SMOKE YOUR WEED, MAN.
>> COME ON, MARCUS.
>> BULL SNAPS, BRO.
I MADE UP MY MIND, MR. H. I
DON'T KNOW WHY YOU BROUGHT YOUR
TIE AND YOUR SHIRT DOWN HERE,
MAN.
WHAT MORE DO YOU WANT FOR ME?
>> I WAS ACTUALLY HOPING TO
SCORE SOME SHROOMS.
I GOT A BACHELOR PARTY.
I PROMISED MY BUDDIES I'D PICK
UP SOME SHROOMS.
IF POSS, MAYBE GET THEM BEFORE
NEXT FRIDAY?
>> YEAH, I THINK WE COULD DO
BUSINESS.
>> NAH.
>> THIS IS A TEST, RIGHT?
YOU'RE TRYING TO MAKE ME LEARN?
>> NO, IT'S DEFINITELY NOT THAT,
I WANT TO TRY AND BUY SOME
SHROOMS, EITHER FROM YOU OR
SOMEBODY YOU KNOW.
>> YEAH, MAN, COME THROUGH
TOMORROW.
>> ALL RIGHT.
MARCUS, HOPE TO SEE YOU IN CLASS
SOMETIME SOON.
>> YO, MR. H.
>> YEAH?
>> WHAT DID THE GUIDANCE
COUNSELOR SAY?
>> ABOUT WHAT?
>> AFTER YOU SHOWED HIM MY
ESSAY, HE SAID SOMETHING TO YOU.
WHAT DID HE SAY?
>> HE SAID THAT IT WAS A LITTLE
ALL OVER THE PLACE.
>> JUST LIKE ME.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]